another quarterback who will be present
and a guy that we talked about a lot
more than trevor lawrence because we
knew where trevor lawrence was going we
didn't know where trey lance was going
we didn't know what the 49ers were going
to do he will be at rookie minicamp and
he said among other things i can't wait
to have teammates again this is a guy
whose team north dakota state played one
game last year
one game and i still don't know what the
49ers are doing and i don't know how
many years trey lance is going to sit on
the bench he's already got one year
where he didn't play much football is
there going to be a second year where it
doesn't play much football is there
going to be a third year where he
doesn't play much football who knows but
at least for him he commences the
process of getting up to speed and i
think it's a crash course because
ideally what the 49ers should want
is trey lance to be ready to go that the
coaching staff believes it the locker
room believes it he's ready to go
jimmy g you go to him late august and
you say hey we need to cut your pay to
12 million or it's take a hike time
that's what they should hope they're
able to do if they can't trade him you
don't pay him 25 million you don't have
to pay him 25 million the guy that we
gave up three first round picks and a
third round pick to get is ready to go
right exactly and this i mean it reminds
me of the carson wentz situation and
it's an easy comp to make especially
because we're talking about two north
dakota state qbs but look i think
everybody
thought or at least the prevailing
thought was at that time in 2016 that
carson wentz was not going to
necessarily start the season as the
starter
because they had somebody like sam
bradford but as time went on it became
clear
that carson wins could start in week one
and so then when that catastrophic knee
injury happens with teddy bridgewater in
uh minnesota then sam bradford gets to
be traded and the eagles pick up an
extra pick so i i think you don't first
of all you never hope for anybody to get
like a catastrophic knee injury that's
something that you certainly don't want
to see but
usually something happens in august and
i think that at a certain point
uh the 49ers are probably going to say
to themselves well if we can get
something for jimmy garoppolo then
that's probably what we want to do
because at least that's the ideal
situation because you don't want trey
lance i think to sit for another season
of football it has been so long since he
was playing football consistently what
you're talking about man i can't wait to
have teammates again because it's been
that long since you you've had them
since you've been able to go out there
and compete with guys and that's
something the qb's love you know they
love to be part of the guys they love to
be leaders they love to be teammates
so if that's what usually if that's what
they want then that i think is gonna
really kind of help trey lance to be
like all right i need to come in here
and i need to establish myself as
somebody who is going to challenge jimmy
garoppolo for this starting quarterback
job for week one and i think it's gonna
be interesting to see how this plays out
over the next couple months
yeah and crash course learn the offense
get kyle shanahan to the point where he
can trust this guy i think that is one
of the key aspects of the trey lance and
any young quarterback for kyle shanahan
can i trust you
are you the guy that can be and chris
sims always talks about this as it
relates to john gruden
it's his high-end performance sports car
and you have the keys to it as the
quarterback can you be trusted with
those keys that's going to be one of the
challenges for kyle shanahan and if
there is any truth to the idea and i
think there is truth to the idea that
he wanted mac jones when they traded up
six seven weeks ago
to get the pick that became trey lance
that may make him
more likely
to not
be willing to hand the keys over
immediately and maybe they are maybe
they are locked into jimmy garoppolo for
you the thing about the 49ers if they're
trying to create the impression
among the rest of us that we don't know
what they're doing they're succeeding
because i don't know what they're doing
and i really do wonder at times whether
when we look at the broader scope since
march 26 when they made the trade
whether they know what they're doing
miles
well look i mean since that day when you
and i got on the air on pftpm we've been
saying that jimmy garoppolo is not long
for this world with the 49ers i mean we
didn't quite go as far as kyle shanahan
when he said that you know we might not
all even make it to sunday but
i think it was pretty clear that you
don't want to pay jimmy garoppolo 20 the
25 million dollars he's owed especially
when you go up that far and you pick a
qb like i it just doesn't seem like
something that they should do like
logically with the wall that we know
about the nfl mic with all the years
you've been covering the nfl it just
doesn't seem like something that they
should do following everything that we
know about what it takes for
quarterbacks you know and and especially
now in this day and age where you
basically have three years to figure out
if your quarterback is good or not
because otherwise you don't know what to
do with that fifth year option you don't
know what to do when it comes to signing
them to a long term extension so
by the from the time that you draft a
guy that clock starts so that clock is
now it's ticking man and so i think that
they have to figure out what they're
going to do with trey lansin i think
especially because he hasn't played as
much football you got to get him out
there on the field sooner than later so
you can actually see what he's doing and
plus i don't like
i don't necessarily know the intricacies
of the kyle shannon offense but i do
feel like if there is a scheme that
protects what the qb does it's that one
and think about what brian hoyer did
with the browns in 2014. think how good
um that matt ryan looked in 2016
with that offense like there's a way i
feel like for a rookie to come in there
so that he can do something and then get
out on the field and look really good so
i don't know i i still tend to think
that he'll be lance will be out there
sooner than later and jimmy garoppolo
won't be there
it really is a strange situation you
have a quarterback who took you to the
super bowl when healthy possibly not
because of his skills but because of the
offense remember when kyle got freaked
out against the vikings in the
divisional round it became bob greasy
playing quarterback for the 49ers until
the super bowl and then he missed the
throw in the super bowl that was a
championship throw that could have won
the trophy for the 49ers and now this
idea that they've pivoted away from
garoppolo because he can't stay healthy
so they give up three ones and a three
to get his replacement but we're not
replacing him
with his replacement just yet we're
going to reserve the right to have him
as jed york the ceo of the team said
recently for up to two more years
it just doesn't fit
because there are other alternatives
first of all you could have sat at 12
and see who fell to you and you don't
have to give up two extra ones in a
three to get another quarterback maybe
trey lance would have been there mac
jones was there now
and that's the thing the 49ers that
weren't one of those teams that we would
have circled as oh there's a quarterback
hot spot it would have been a surprise
just like it would have been a surprise
for the vikings to take justin fields at
14 the fields had been there we'd have
been like holy crap look at this they
just keep their mouths shut they could
have set it up and if all else fails
take a guy in in one of the later rounds
and develop him to be
a real backup to jimmy garoppolo a guy
you can trust not like cj beathard nick
mullins and then give garoppolo one more
year if you believe in what the guy can
do when he's healthy
then give him another year to see if he
can be healthy i mean he was healthy all
of 2019. just because he tore his acl in
2018 and suffered an ankle injury last
year that caused him to miss 10 games
that doesn't mean he's gonna like tumble
down the steps like gerald ford and not
playing any games this year there's a
timely reference for you it it
so i i just i don't i don't get how this
is happening miles and i'm gonna revert
back to something that i've said
recently i think that they're so freaked
out by the fact
that they didn't
bite on patrick mahomes in 2017 that
they told tom brady no thank you to his
bay area homecoming last year we're good
with jimmy g
those two things have caused them
to do
some things that to an outsider might
look a little kooky because i think
they're getting desperate to rectify
their past mistakes well that's an
interesting point because i think that
whenever you start to think about you
know what i didn't do in life you know
oh man i have this regret because i i
didn't do x and i didn't do y and so
that sets up yourself to say well i'm
gonna do it different now for z right
and and i guess that that's kind of
what's happening but you know you say
like
they're saying that they you still
believe in jimmy garoppolo well
obviously you don't because you don't
trade up you know all those picks to get
to number three to obviously take a
quarterback if you believe in the guy
that you have you just don't do that i
mean it's the same thing that you could
have said about kansas city and alex
smith in 2017 right you don't trade up
to get to number 10 overall and then
select a guy and then you're saying oh
yeah we still believe in this
quarterback that we have i mean
obviously you really don't because you
no matter what you think
it around no matter what you say you
clearly think that in order to actually
win a championship in order to actually
bring home the lombardi trophy you had
to go up and get this guy right and so
it obviously worked in kansas city
they've raised the trophy and they've
been to two consecutive super bowls and
since uh patrick holmes has been
starting they haven't finished any worse
in the afc championship game it remains
to be seen how that's going to work in
san francisco because i don't know if
it's really that much of a viable option
to still say yeah jimmy garoppolo you're
our starter all year you got to figure
he's going to get hurt at some point
just based on the history and then trey
lance is going to be in there anyway so
i don't know it just
obviously from what they their actions
have shown that they do not believe that
jimmy garoppolo is a super bowl winning
quarterback
i last point
i just love to know what the 49ers would
do if the packers would call them up now
and say
how about nick bosa george kittle
you know because it's not like they have
first round draft picks together right
but start picking names off the roster
we'll give you aaron rodgers what would
they do and uh yeah and if if they'd
have had tom brady fall in their lap
this year versus last year they probably
would have said yes because this is the
year they decided they can no longer
trust jimmy g to be on the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports